a racy conversation between tormund and
Brienne Cersei in a blood-soaked bed and
Jon's farewell to ghost were all chopped
from season seven of Game of Thrones
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and today I'm looking at some of the
best scenes that ended up cut from the
seventh season of HBO's mega popular
fantasy series by the way my Game of
Thrones Funko pop giveaway is also
running on this video so for a chance to
win make sure you're subscribed to my
channel and leave a comment with your
thoughts about the deleted scenes or the
show in general and quick warning I'm
talking spoilers for all seasons and
speculation for season eight the
fearsome wildling leader tormund
Giantsbane is one of my favorite
characters on the show and he's had some
fantastic moments that bring a loss of
hero to the series and ever since season
6 when he first laid eyes on the mighty
warrior Brienne of Tarth the formidable
torment has been struck down with puppy
love there have been some hilarious
scenes of torment eyeing up Brienne and
so far she's ignored his advances but
fans of the pair may be sad to know that
some lines of rather racy dialogue
between the two were cut from this
season's very first episode the last
moment took place after torment
approached Brienne and Winterfell as she
was sparring with Podrick
the red haired wildling was going to try
flirting with Brienne by telling her
about his experience with she loved the
burn you can see a little clip still in
the episode where Brienne walks off in
disgust whilst answer a little finger
are talking overhead this would have
been a funny callback to season 4 when
tormund tried to impress his fellow
waddling x' with his story claiming he'd
had carnal relations with a bear that
was a night to remember
fans were sharp but she knew how to use
nice she was no ordinary Beast Ygritte
was having none of tomans tall tales
back then and clearly Brienne wasn't
impressed by it either or as the actor
who plays tormund says she didn't like
his pickup line
which is hardly surprising for all sorts
of reasons including her own experience
having to fight a bear when she was
captured by Bolton men back in season 3
in fact Brienne is pretty uncomfortable
generally with the whole Tallman
situation which was made clear in a
deleted scene from season 6 it showed
Sansa teasing her about tormund's
interest
which sent the great warrior into a
fluster of embarrassment still I do hope
tormund and Brienne survive at least a
good few episodes next season so we can
see their paths cross again
by the way tormund's attempted
flirtation with breanna Winterfell
wasn't the only moment featuring the
wildling talking about furs it ended up
cut this season in episode 6 when a
giant and dead polar bear appeared out
of nowhere to attack Jon Snow's ranging
party the first words out of tormance
mouth were I've danced with plenty of
bears though that line sadly hit the
editing room floor and the premiere
episode also cooked down another scene
this time with Sam and Gilly it's during
the scene with Samus studying books in
the Citadel's restricted library and
remembers about the mountain of
dragonglass sitting beneath dragon stone
in that scene Gilly picked up a book
called legends of the long night and
started to read herself
unfortunately the part where Gilly reads
aloud from the book was reportedly curse
out so he missed out on hearing some
very interesting lines including the
following the white cold rose up and the
walkers rose with it and the Sun hid its
face for a lifetime ashamed that
something non could discover in the
cutscene Gilly claims she knows what
made the Sun do that and tell Sam that
Craster was drunk once when the time
came to give one of his baby boys away
and he told the child come on time to
meet your brothers Gilly also reveals
that some of Craster's older wives
referred to the White Walkers as
Craster's sons Gilly then thinks back to
the time when a white Walker attacked
her Sam and her baby and questions
whether he was actually one of her
brothers now I wonder whether this scene
was cut because the audience already
knows about Craster sons being turned
into White Walkers which we saw in
season four however it's not clear
whether any living character on the show
really knows this though Jon Snow did
catch a glimpse of one of Craster's sons
being taken in season 2 maybe Gilley's
reveal will be included next season
instead especially if it makes a
difference to how the living can defeat
the army of the Dead but it's a shame
that gillies lines were cut this season
as they would have made her role a bit
more meaningful and they would also
highlighted her part in uncovering
important information even if my chance
like she did an episode 5 with Rhaegar
annulment of his marriage to LEM
tell and while we're on the subject of
scenes with Sam the first episode showed
a humorous montage of what life was like
for the budding Meister after he arrived
at the Citadel and although it felt
plenty long enough as it was there's
actually an editor the scene which is 7
to 8 minutes long which the episode
director has described as hilarious so
perhaps we'll see that as a blue-ray
extra we finally got to see aya briefly
reunite with her long-lost direwolf
Nymeria this season but our other
favorite direwolf ghost was sadly
chopped from his only scene which was
planned for episode 2 according to the
season 7 outline there was a short scene
where ghosts sawed John off from
Winterfell as he left the Dragons stone
in the cutscene Jon told his direwolf
look after anyone named stark boy which
feels like a touch of irony from the
writers given the full reveal of Jon's
true heritage later in the season it's a
shame that ghost was um ghosted this
season but the reason was probably
financial Game of Thrones budget for
special effects would have already been
stretched with the need for a lot more
dragon and white Walker action and
apparently died wolves are more
expensive to animate than CGI dragons I
suspect also a decision was made that we
should see Nymeria instead she hasn't
been seen since aya had to leave her in
the woods in season 1 and their reunion
underlined just how much has changed for
each of them since then in fact this
isn't the first time that ghost has had
his screen time cut down as the scene
was deleted from season 6 were ghosts
menaced Alliser Thorne and other nights
Watchmen and according to the director
of battle the bastards ghost was going
to have a big part in that episode but
it was just too expensive and when they
had to choose between one one and the
dire wolf they picked the mighty giant
instead one character who brings some
humor to most scenes he's in his brawn
so it was a shame that the scene of him
and Tyrion having a little reunion that
was originally intended to be in the
fifth episode was dropped from filming
it looks like it would have occurred
just before Jamie arrives at a secret
meeting with Tyrion that bran helps set
up in King's Landing of course we did
finally see the two men back together on
screen in the season finale though given
how much fun the scenes they share
together often are it would have been
great to see more of them Littlefinger's
death was a long time coming in Game of
Thrones and it took
seven seasons of is scheming to finally
come crashing down on him before the
Starks realized that he was the one
who'd set everything in motion
Sansa even admitted that she was a slow
learner in the final episode after still
getting played by Littlefinger
throughout much of season seven in fact
there's a deleted scene where Sansa goes
to brands are asking for his help before
she executes her own sister I am actor
Isaac Hempstead right he plays bran
revealed in an interview with variety
that it suddenly occurred to Sansa that
she had a huge CCTV Department at her
discretion and it might be a good idea
to check with him first before she guts
her own sister so she goes to bran and
brand tells her everything she needs to
know according to him stood right they
did actually film this scene but I can
see a couple of possibilities for why it
got the chop on the one hand if it had
been included it would have taken away
from the drama of the scene where Sansa
caused aya in and it looks like she's
about to sentence Iyer to death but then
she turns the tables on Littlefinger
also the deleted scene further
highlights answers ongoing naivety given
the fact she was still getting
manipulated by Littlefinger and
ultimately needed brans help to figure
out what was really going on the season
finale set up numerous storylines for
palace into season 8 but there is one
crucial scene detailed in the episode
outline which didn't make it into the
final episode the cutscene would have
occurred just after Jamie stormed off
from King's Landing and discussed
following Circe's refusal to honor her
agreement to send the Lannister army
north against the night king the scene
is set at the red keeping King's Landing
and her surfy waking up suddenly in the
middle of the night to discover her
bedclothes covered in blood this scene
which implies Cersei has just miscarried
would have made a big difference to
house season 7 ended and it feels like
it would also have had strong parallels
with the scene we saw in the finale of
Lyanna stark lying in a bloody bed
having just given birth as season seven
left Cersei still apparently pregnant
though her future baby has already given
rise to a number of fan theories one
such theory is that Tyrion has made a
deal with Cersei behind Danny's back to
arrange for Circe's new child to inherit
the iron throne after Daenerys we know
that Tyrion was concerned about the
succession and Downey's apparent
inability to have children but what we
don't know is if he had to agree to
something in order to change
Circe's mind and make her publicly
support Danny and John Tyrion didn't
look very happy when Danny and John were
hooking up at the end of the episode
either likely because of the political
problems their romantic relationship
could cause burst if that Searcy fan
theory is correct
Tyrion could also be worried that if
Danny does conceive her own child it was
scuffle his deal with his sister in any
case I do wonder whether this cutscene
has been moved to season 8 meaning that
we might still see Cersei miscarry
indeed her miscarriage may be
foreshadowed in Jaime's words to his
sister that our child will never be born
if the dead come south of course Jaime
was thinking of the knight Kings undead
army but technically the undead have
already come south in the form of the
white that John and Danny brought to the
dragon pit I think the way the white
clawed at Cersei after it came
dangerously close to her could also be
some ominous foreshadowing for Cersei
and her baby
for example Cersei could die either
through miscarriage or in childbirth
which could fulfill the valonqar
prophecy that I talked about in detail
in my video predicting who will die in
season 8 alternately it is possible that
the showrunners have decided to go the
route of Cersei lying about being
pregnant so the scene could have been
cut for that reason so what do you think
about the season 7 deleted scenes and do
you think any of them should have been
included also what were your best and
worst moments of this season let me know
what you think in the comments below and
also don't forget to subscribe for your
chance to win an awesome game of Thrones
Funko pop the winner of my last giveaway
for a defenders or Punisher Funko pop is
on screen right now if that's you then
send me a message with your details so I
can send you the prize if you enjoyed
this hit that thumbs up button and also
check out my predictions on which
characters are most likely to die in the
final season of Game of Thrones or you
can watch more of my deleted scenes
videos by tapping the screen right here
thanks for watching and see you next
time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers